bonjour a priori on sait tous comment
respirer hockey dans le doute je vous
invite à vérifier
on dit des créatifs qu'elles sont des
personnes inspirées
donc je vous invite tout de suite à
tester le niveau de votre créativité en
inspirant de manière continue et le plus
longtemps possible
pendant que je vous explique pourquoi
les créatifs ont aussi besoin d'expirer
quand on pense à une personne créative
on imagine un original qui a mille idées
à la seconde
un curieux un touche à tout qui va
proposer des solutions saugrenue à des
problèmes improbable mais c'est aussi
quelqu'un à qui on reproche souvent de
changer d'avis tout le temps de ne pas
respecter les délais quand il doit
rendre un projet ou de cela s'est très
vite la créativité c'est la capacité à
créer du nouveau ce qui signifie deux
choses un être capable de curiosité pour
se changer les idées et deux de mettre
en oeuvre ses idées c'est à dire de les
expiré donc c'est justement là que tout
se complique quand les anges de la mise
en oeuvre s'intensifie et que là la
créativité la matière première vraiment
de votre profession comme c'est le cas
pour les métiers artistiques et bien
vous devez tenir bon même dans les pires
à sion donc prenez matt stone et trey
parker
les créateurs de south park il enchaîne
l'écriture des épisodes à une semaine
d'intervalle ils ont une capacité
d'improvisation qui est phénoménal
mais quand vient l'heure de taper les
dialogues trey parker perd toute
motivation et se bourre de burger pour
donner du courage
au sixième jour ils sont déprimés tous
les deux est persuadé qu'ils ont foré
l'épisode pendant ce temps là des
millions de fans attendent rivet
derrière leur écran
c'est comme ça chaque semaine et en 19
saisons parker et stone ne manquait
qu'une seule diffusion est encore à
cause d'une panne d'électricité dans
leur studio pour une personne inspiré la
mise en oeuvre peut être vraiment un
calvaire votre esprit divergent vous
assailli de questions sur quels critères
je vais fonder mes choix
comment être sûr que je vais pas perdre
l'originalité de mon idée en cours de
route
comment être sûr de ne pas jeter quelque
chose d'important
pourquoi est ce que les décisions du
collectif nivelles tel toujours par le
bas ou à quel moment je suis sûr que mon
projet est terminé
les dictionnaires donne 3 définition du
verbe expiré et épuisé les l'air contenu
dans les poumons atteindre les limites
d'une échéance et rendre l'âme
évidemment moi quand j'ai commencé mes
études de cinéma à l'âge de 15 ans
personne m'a annoncé ce programme là et
pourtant c'est dans cette expiration que
je vais trouver l'inspiration
entre mon bac audiovisuel et mes études
dans une école parisienne j'ingurgite
tout ce que je peux sur les techniques
de réalisation d'un film de l'optique à
la production en passant par le montage
découpage technique
le mixage et j'en passe et à 20 ans je
découvre le cinéma documentaire c'est le
format idéal pour pallier à mes
problèmes d'inspiration boulimique une
caméra une équipe réduite
pas de décor pas de comédien et pas
d'argent les films documentaires sont
des films inclassables
vous les trouverez au rayon dvd coincé
entre tous sur la guerre 14 18 et
cuisses abdos fessiers comment retrouver
la ligne après des triplés sont des
ovnis des objets films et non identifiés
dont vous vous demandez s'il raconte
vraiment une histoire comment ça se fait
qu'il y ait des effets spéciaux ou
pourquoi c'est martin scorsese qui l'a
réalisé non c'est pas parce que martin
scorsese fait des films de fitness c'est
parce que la matière première des
documentaires c'est le réel et que dans
le réel
tout est possible y compris la façon de
raconter en 2003 je suis en train de
préparer un film sur le processus
artistique
quand je rencontre le théâtre dès minuit
c'est une compagnie de théâtre qui est
en train de commencer une nouvelle
création collective qui s'intitule la
forteresse du coup je m'enferme avec eux
pendant huit mois et durant tout ce
temps je scrute dans les répétitions les
confrontations entre les partis pris
personnel et les décisions du collectif
dans une troupe comme celle ci la
respiration est la suivante les
comédiens expiré épuisent le thème du
spectacle pendant des semaines par leurs
improvisations
il arrive qu'il y ait unanimité sur une
scène il arrive aussi que soient les
plus anciens qui tranche
mais il est du ressort du metteur en
scène de veiller à la cohérence finale
de l'oeuvre avec plus ou moins de tact
avec plus ou moins d'autorité mais les
garants de ce qui doit expirer en bout
de ligne chez les minuit ce rôle est
remis en question à chaque spectacle
c'est comme si pour créer quelque chose
de nouveau
il fallait forcément emprunter un chemin
inédit alors à la fin du tournage j'ai
90 heures de rushes et pas d'histoire
parce que en cinq ans d'études pratique
personne n'a jugé bon de m'apprendre les
techniques narratives
pas de bol du coup comme ma petite soeur
est en train d'étudier les récits à
l'école je vous demande de me faire
court mais ça nous prend un an avec le
monteur pour arriver à achever le film
et on en ressort épuisé
entre temps le producteur a disparu avec
un tiers du budget et a fermé sa boîte
inspiré par de nouvelles aventures en
documentaire il ya une règle d'or qu'on
ne brise pas on ne doit pas s'impliquer
avec les sujets d'un film comme j'ai
aussi besoin de trouver du travail pour
vivre
du coup je deviens comédienne pour le
théâtre dès minuit
à peine j'entre dans la troupe que du
coup on part en tournée j'apprends à
jouer sur les scènes d'europe de l'est
et mes nouveaux collègues m'associer à
leur jeu comme si j'avais toujours su
quoi faire devant 500 spectateurs
et finalement je découvre que en les
ayant observé pendant 18 mois à la fois
pendant le tournage mais aussi pendant
le montage j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses sur mon nouveau métier
finalement vous appropriant un événement
différemment en épuisant un échec
vous risquez fort de tomber sur une
opportunité en 2006 on part en tournée
en haïti l'institut français nous
accueille avec une liste exhaustive de
restriction ne pas sortir de l'hôtel
ne pas manger de fruits et légumes crus
bien se couvrir à la tombée de la nuit
pour ne pas être dévorés par les
moustiques et accessoirement éviter
d'attraper le paludisme en cas
d'enlèvement ne pas résister ici le
kidnapping est un business toute façon
au pire on sera relâchée trois jours
plus tard l'avion qui doit nous emmener
à l'autre bout du pays est en panne du
coup on traverse en minibus sur des
pistes défoncées et sans s'arrêter pour
ne pas rouler la nuit et éviter de
heurter les habitants qui circulent à
pied d'un village à un autre les troupes
locales de théâtre nous invite à les
rencontrer
on est vraiment impressionné les voir
créer dans ces conditions et leur cadre
de travail est 100 fois plus
contraignant que le nôtre mais comme
leur envie de créer leur envie de jouer
dedans c'est passe avant tout il se pose
pas de questions ils trouvent des
solutions et nous on prend la plus
grande leçon créativité de notre
histoire de troupes
on a toujours joué malgré les
contraintes mais en haïti on en fait
vraiment un devoir
au bout de deux semaines la turista
terrasse la compagnie est le metteur en
scène et moi savons encore les deux
salles à tenir debout
du coup on récupère tout le monde trois
heures avant les représentations en
l'école devant la table à maquillage et
on les catapultes sur scène
heureusement
pour un comédien la scène est un endroit
magique vous récupérer de l'énergie
même quand vous en avez plus mais
heureusement aussi qu'on joue dehors
parce qu'en coulisse on peut venir dans
les buissons
ce qui est assez pratique surtout quand
vous avez cinq kilos de costumes arnage
et sur le dos le visage intégralement
maquiller et qu'il est hors de question
de le retoucher parce que vous vouliez
du passé deux heures une autre astuce
consiste à vous et à les trois
centimètres de talent que sur le visage
pour éviter que les couleurs dégouline
dans la chaleur ce qu'il ya aussi
l'avantagé de vous protéger contre les
moustiques atteindre ses limites et
s'amusait à les dépasser
c'est vraiment le meilleur antidote que
je connaisse contre la lassitude dans un
projet quelques années plus tard
comédienne quitte la troupe et moi je
veux récupérer un de ses rôles in
extremis celui d'une veuve de guerre
évidemment metteur en scène en profite
pour reprendre le texte donc une heure
avant d'entrer en scène
bah il est toujours dessus j'ai jamais
répéter le personnage j'ai pas non plus
de costumes
je dois jouer parmi les spectateurs
et en plus la veuve ouvre le spectacle
autant dire qu'elle donne le ton en
coulisses j'attrape un vieux drap noir
ignifuges et et je le jette sur mes
épaules
quand les lumières s'éteignent je me
glisse parmi les spectateurs j'ai le
coeur qui bat tellement fort que j'ai
peur qu'ils me remarque dans l'obscurité
quand je m'assieds le souffle du drap
qui retombe m'aide à me concentrer et je
m'accroche aux premières répliques sans
trop savoir ce qui vient ensuite à côté
de moi il ya une femme qui sursautent le
texte déroule tout seul presque son moi
et il me sert à la gorge j'ai des images
de pleureuses dans la tête des femmes
qui sont habillés tout en noir et qui
viennent sur la place d'un village pour
chercher le nom de leur mari disparu sur
des listes qui sont affichées sur les
murs du village
al après la représentation la femme qui
a sursauté à côté de moi viens me voir
je la reconnais puisque sa fille vient
d'avoir un oscar et du coup je m'apprête
à la féliciter violement teront pour
m'expliquer à quel point le personnage
de la veuve l'à beaucoup touché
ce qui me permet de vérifier en passant
que ce que j'ai dit était pas tout à
fait n'importe quoi en tant
qu'autodidacte j'ai beaucoup cherché la
reconnaissance et le retour de mes pairs
et qui a toujours été quelque chose
d'essentiel ce que ça m'a permis de
m'appuyer dessus pour pour avancer
mais le travail de création ne prend
tout son sens que quand il est rendu
public
parce que c'est à ce moment là que vous
devez faire le deuil de quelque chose
qui vous tient vraiment à coeur pour que
d'autres puissent se l'approprier et
éventuellement sont inspirés c'est ça
que moi j'entends par rendre l'âme
c'est dans la concrétisation de son
projet qu un créatif devient créateur
épuisé atteindre les limites et rendre
l'âme
ces trois stratégies d'expiration
peuvent lui permettre d'inspirer à
nouveau parce qu'au bout de l'ex pire ya
l'inspirent ça revient c'est un
processus naturel
en tout cas j'espère que ça a été le cas
pour ce qu ont joué le jeu et qui
inspire depuis tout à l'heure à force de
péripéties j'ai fini par trouver un
métier qui soit à la croisée de tout ce
que j'avais vu qu avant aujourd'hui je
suis facilitatrice en créativité pour
les professionnels ce qui signifie que
j'accompagne les créateurs dans ce
voyage entre leur vision et sa
réalisation est de plus en plus mon
métier consiste à identifier avec eux
les ressources qu'ils ont déjà en main
et qu'ils n'exploitent pas pendant de
temps ou par manque de prise de recul de
creuser les problèmes en cours pour y
dénicher des occasions de se dépasser et
de développer ses propres stratégies
quand j'ai commencé ce métier j'avais 30
ans et mes nouveaux collègues avec tous
au moins quinze ans d'expérience
en marketing de l'innovation en
management en conduite de changement
du coup moi pour inspirer mais quinze
prochaines années
j'ai expirer les 15 dernières j'ai remis
à jour mais expérience une expérience
c'est une découverte fondatrice tiré
d'un projet hasardeuse que vous avez
vécu à fond une expérience n'a rien à
voir avec le nombre de projets que vous
avez menées ou avec le nombre d'années
que vous avez exercé un métier c'est pas
du tout ce qu'on vous demande sur un cv
une expérience c'est plutôt un acquis
personnels que vous pouvez transposer
dans n'importe quel domaine
c'est une balise sur laquelle vous
pouvez vous appuyer quand vous créez
quelque chose de nouveau et qu'il n'y a
pas de se dessiner rers tout tracé parce
que tant qu'à être un original autant
s'inspirer de ses origines merci